germany has reported its highest seven
day incidence rate of covert 19 cases
yet with over with infections registered
at over 900 per 100 000 people for the
first time health authorities recorded
164 000 new cases in a single 24-hour
period
the rise is driven largely by the
dominant omicron variant
the german parliament is set to debate
compulsory vaccines later on later today
the government has already passed
legislation that will make vaccines
required for health care workers from
march
unvaccinated staff could be banned from
work or even fired
we spoke to a nurse who works in a
coveted ward herself but says she won't
get vaccinated whatever the risk
today zabina schroeder is working as an
alternative practitioner she offers her
patients homeopathy treatments
on other days she works as a nurse in an
intensive care unit
when the pandemic started she
volunteered in a coveted ward even local
newspapers reported on this story
it is a smaller intensive care unit but
over 50 of it was occupied by
coronavirus patients
during my shifts i've really experienced
how desperately patients were struggling
for air
that really got to me
from her own experience she knows that
the disease has cost many lives however
she doesn't want to get vaccinated
against covet 19 even though it will be
compulsory for healthcare workers in
germany from march
instead of being vaccinated with a
vaccine whose effect i can't assess i'd
rather catch the virus
of course that could go badly but then i
would rather accept death on my own
terms
lawmaker and dr paola pishota voted for
compulsory vaccinations
she wants to prevent patients from being
infected by nursing staff
for all of us working in healthcare it
is our job that we do not put our
patients at unreasonable risk
and the covet-19 vaccination is
extremely safe which is why it is
acceptable to enforce it to protect our
patients
sabina believes in alternative therapy
not in vaccinations despite all the
scientific proof that they work
most healthcare workers are vaccinated
but zabina could now lose her clinical
job
and my employer would say
we are a danger to the patients
then i will accept that
then i will not work there anymore
she would then be missing out on several
hundred euros a month but that won't
change her mind she says she will remain
unvaccinated
for more let's bring in our political
correspondent emmanuel chaz emma german
parliamentarians today are debating a
blanket mandate for covid19 vaccinations
what are they considering exactly
well terry what's really important to
realize what's happening today is not a
vote it is a round of discussions only
there's no mandatory vaccine that will
be decided here in germany uh today
parliamentarians of all
parties in favor or against the mandate
will debate between themselves on
whether or not they want this mandate to
be voted and on the feasibility
of this mandate they're supported in
that by
president federal president frankvarter
frankwatersteinmeier he had highlighted
a few days ago how important that debate
was he said that of course
the state is under pressure to act
timely in these times of pandemic but
also he said that this didn't replace
the requirement to weigh up
arguments and balance
arguments and balance interests that are
at stake this is precisely what we're
going to see today in the parliament and
it's a very
hardly debated topic also here within
the german population even if two thirds
of the population are actually in favor
of a mandatory vaccine it's not really
uh black and white and maybe let's
listen directly to what some people had
to say about a mandatory vaccine
really it's probably right to make it
mandatory for people who work a lot with
others
from teachers to health care workers
overall i'd say that i'm in favor but
also that i'm not sure
i'm personally against making
vaccination mandatory for some groups of
the population only for example for
health care workers
to me this would be the worst solution
and i say either you make it mandatory
for everyone or for no one
everybody should do it
of course
now there's a big rush but people have
had so much time to get vaccinated
i've also done it and i just think it's
the right thing to do so
i'm in favor of making vaccinations
mandatory because i think that everybody
should watch out for each other and make
sure that we get out of this pandemic at
last
emma if the german parliament does end
up approving a blanket vaccine mandate
do they have any idea how it could be
enforced
well here's uh where it might be
difficult for germany for one
even within the governing coalition it
might be problematic to agree on a
mandatory vaccine while they agree that
a general mandate
could be implemented uh they agree on it
only for
people over 18. for example not all
members of the coalition would also go
for a mandatory vaccine three liberals
virgin kubichi for example
he's the vice president of the bundestag
he warned that a mandatory vaccine would
have little effect on the unvaccinated
here in germany and that it would only
lead in his opinion to a wave of
administrate administrative herders uh
with the fines being issued against
unvaccinated and uh both uh the greens
and the fdp the three uh uh democrats
would be in favor of a mandatory vaccine
from a defined age only to protect the
most vulnerable so they would have to
agree uh on that and of course on
how to implement it within the
population
mandatory vaccines highly controversial
our political correspondent emmanuel
shaz thank you so much
you